[Music]
so my first book the happiness
hypothesis was a collection of 10
insights from from sages around the
world that were psychological truths and
one of them is what doesn't kill you
makes you stronger
that gets it the idea of the
psychological principle of antifragility
it's a wonderful term that's actually a
clunky ugly term but it was made up by
Nassim Taleb because we don't have a
word for this in English language which
is that there are some systems that get
stronger if they get pushed around
knocked around so a wine glass is
fragile if you knock it over it breaks
nothing good happens a plastic cup is
resilient if a kid throws it off the
table it doesn't break but nothing good
happens but there's some things that
have to get thrown off the table there's
some systems that have to get pushed
around and to let wrote this book anti
fragile or anti fragility because things
like the banking system had to be tested
where it gets fragile and collapses
bones have to be tested used or they get
weak if you were to fly to Mars your
bones we get weak the immune system if
you protect kids from bacteria if you
keep them in a sterile environment
you're damaging the immune system you
mean the immune system has to face
challenges in order to learn turns out
kids are anti fragile and when we
protect children from unpleasantness
from conflicts from insults from teasing
from exclusion we're preventing their
social psychology we're preventing their
social abilities we're preventing their
strength from developing the subtitle of
our book is how good intentions and bad
ideas are setting up a generation for
failure by over protecting our children
we are setting them up to be weak to be
more easily damaged to be more easily
discouraged the next untruth is always
trust your feelings
it may sound wise it may sound romantic
but wise people around the world have
noticed that that we don't react to the
world as it actually is we react to the
constructions though the perceptions
Epictetus said it is not things
themselves that disturb us but our
interpretations of things this is the
basis of cognitive behavioral therapy
Aaron Beck a psychiatrist in 1960s
noticed that depressed and anxious
people have a way of constructing these
beliefs that I'm bad the future is bad
my future the world is the world is a
bad place and they're mutually
reinforcing and this is the way the
world feels to them and if you can
improve their thinking and break up
those beliefs they're released from the
depression what we what we'd begun
seeing on campus is that students are
encouraged to to follow their feelings
if they feel offended by something then
they have been attacked they're supposed
to not question those feelings but part
of wisdom is the ability to say now wait
a second are there other ways to look at
this these are crucial skills for
critical thinking these are crucial
skills for mental health and we need to
be teaching young people at all stages
to question their first interpretations
look for evidence and improve the way
they interpret the world the third grade
untruth my favorite the worst and most
dangerous and darkest of all is that
life is a battle between good people and
evil people if you think about it for a
moment
who are we what is our species we
evolved in small-scale societies that
were locked and struggle with other
small-scale societies human nature is
really really finely tailored for
intergroup conflict for tribal warfare
this is the way our ancestors lived for
a long time now that we've transcended
it we're so desperate for it we've
invented team sports fraternities we
love these sorts of competitions our
brains are made for it now it can be fun
or it can get dark and it can lead to
racism all kinds of all kinds of forms
of bigotry if we're creating
multi-ethnic environments on campuses
and in most of our organizations were
struggling to increase diversity what
you should obviously be doing is turning
down the tribal sentiments is
emphasizing what we have in common but
on some college campuses and in some
high schools we see forms of education
forms of training that teach students to
make more and more distinctions to see
more and more binary dimensions between
people where the people who are high are
bad the people who are low are good the
more we encourage people to see the
people around them as good versus evil
the harder it's going to be to create an
inclusive diverse environment the bottom
line is that there are some very basic
important psychological principles if
we're gonna raise kids and and educate
them and bring them through schools and
universities we should get our
institutions in line with these
principles they our children are anti
fragile we are all prone to motivated
reasoning in the confirmation bias and
we're all prone to tribalism and black
and white thinking we need to be
educating kids so that they do less of
this stuff if we want to raise a
generation of kids who can deal with
diversity of all kinds who can go out
into a world that's physically actually
quite safe but yet full of offensive
offensive content we need to get our
educational practices in line with these
these three psychological principles not
with the three great untruths
[Music]
you